okay no problemo I'm just gonna take it
oh wait
holy [ __ ] they play the game okay shake
it shake it
dang it
[Music]
game over about the [ __ ] okay yeah
yeah yeah I would assume that's room on
the bottom floor what is - ox know how
to use elevators so I have to follow our
dog and took the elevator
obviously I mean it makes sense and
think about it my dog takes the elevator
all the time you know it's open no less
convenient all right I just go in here
actually I want to say first Oh shake it
like a mother I'm not running run run
it's time to go it's time to go buddy
it's time to go all an exit how nice I
don't care about that dog oh yeah best
video game the best video game
now get that our doc I think I know that
is not your H that's for sure all right
jump all right we get stupid crazy [ __ ]
time Oh yep she's gone she's gone we're
safer buddy
ha ha plants happy it's time we go home
and see your mom or whatever yep see you
see you - how's it going
my name your this grudge montage if you
did feel free to leave a like and add it
to your favorites you would do me a
great favor but if you're not convinced
yet
you might also win this cookie also be
sure to leave a comment about whatever
you want
maybe about how much you want that
cookie but most importantly if you want
to see more of these videos be sure to
subscribe to become a bro today and join
the bro army anyway that's pretty much
it hey comes the brofist
[Music]